the jurogan experience it's something
that people used to call the addictive
personality we don't really call it that
anymore we just use the idea of the
disease model
so we say that somebody has the disease
of addiction
it's a chronic relapsing and remitting
problem
people come to it with different degrees
of vulnerability
and the risk for it can essentially be
summarized as nature nurture and
neighborhood and just to briefly
describe that
if you have a biological parent or
grandparent with addiction you are at
increased risk compared to the general
population of getting addicted yourself
if you have a co-occurring mental
illness you are at increased risk of
getting addicted
if you have certain character traits
like you're more impulsive you have a
hard time putting a break between the
idea to do something and actually doing
it you are are you at increased risk for
addiction so that's kind of all in the
sort of nature
risk category there's also the nurture
piece of it so if you grow up in an
environment where you experience a whole
lot of trauma
you are at increased risk for becoming
addicted if you grew up in an
environment where your caretakers
model
using drugs and alcohol or other
addictive substances or behaviors as a
coping strategy you are an increased
risk of becoming addicted or even if
they just implicitly condone it
and then that brings us to the whole
neighborhood idea
and this i think is a really under
recognized aspect of our risk for
addiction which is just simple access so
if you
live in an environment where you have
more access to highly reinforcing drugs
and behaviors you're more likely to try
them and just simply in being exposed
especially with the increasing potency
variety and novelty of drugs today your
increased risk of becoming addicted so
if you go see a doctor who's more free
with their prescription pad you're
exposed to opioids or benzos you're more
likely to to get addicted if you grow up
in a culture where people are playing a
lot of video games you're more likely to
try them more likely to get addicted so
this nature nurture and neighborhood are
the risk factors but again people bring
different degrees of vulnerability to
this problem of addiction and some
people are
more vulnerable than others and you may
indeed be in that category where you're
just some somebody who you know once you
find something that's reinforcing for
you you just go whoop
and you just want to do it again and
again and again when you say reinforcing
what do you mean by that i mean that
it's rewarding in some way rewarding
right so it's it's
it's pleasurable at first
now the thing about addiction and the
way that it changes our brains is that
that thing that initially is pleasurable
and has us engaging in approach
behaviors
if we continue to consume that substance
or engage in that behavior it ultimately
actually puts us in a dopamine deficit
state such that we want to continue to
do that behavior not to feel good but
just to stop feeling bad
and that's kind of one of the
fundamental things about the disease of
addiction it's innate vulnerability to
start
added to the changes that occur in the
brain as a result of
ongoing consumption of our drug and
those brain changes are what drive
continued compulsive use so that's the
difference between being enthusiastic
about something that you enjoy
versus something that consumes your life
so you're kind of chasing the dragon
like the initial fur like that's what
they talk about it with heroin addiction
right don't they say chasing the dragon
yeah the initial rush that you get from
the first
um uses of it
you're always chasing that but really
what you're doing later on in life is
just trying to not be sick yes not
having it in your body makes you feel
terrible right so so interesting that
that term chasing the dragon it comes in
part from as you describe
like the elusiveness of trying to
recreate that initial high which with
continued use becomes harder and harder
but it also literally comes from
when heroin is inhaled so if you put it
on a piece of tin foil and you light it
underneath you get this kind of smoke
then that plume looks like a dragon's
tail so it's got a couple of different
meanings but yes um i mean what you're
saying is exactly right and the way that
i describe this to patients and describe
it
to medical students is imagine that in
your brain there's a balance
kind of like a teeter-totter in a kid's
playground and one of the most
interesting findings in neuroscience in
the past 75 years is that pleasure and
pain are co-located which means the same
parts of our brain that process pleasure
also process pain and they work like
opposite sides of a balance so when we
do something that's rewarding or
reinforcing or pleasurable our balance
tips slightly to the side of pleasure we
get a little release of dopamine the
pleasure neurotransmitter in that part
of our brain our reward pathway and we
feel good but the thing about that
balance is that it wants to remain level
and the brain will work very hard to
restore a level balance or what's called
homeostasis and it does that by tipping
the brain an equal and opposite amount
to the side of pain so again the way the
balance restores homeostasis is to tip
to the opposite side that's the come
down after using that moment of wanting
to do it again the hangover
if we wait long enough that feeling
passes and balance is restored but if we
don't wait
and we continue to use our drug again
and again
we end up with a balance that's
essentially weighted to the side of pain
and i imagine that like these little
neural adaptation gremlins hopping on
the pain side of the balance not very
scientific i know but the point is that
with repeated use we get enough gremlins
on the pain side of the balance to fill
this whole room and then we're
essentially working from a dopamine
deficit state we've down regulated our
own dopamine we've down regulated our
own dopamine transmission and those
gremlins like it on the balance so they
don't get off after the hangover is over
or the acute withdrawal they can persist
there for weeks to months to years
which is why people with addiction
even when their lives have become so
much better will relapse because they're
not walking around with a level pleasure
pain balance they're walking around with
the balance tipped to the side of pain
they're experiencing the universal
symptoms of withdrawal from any
addictive substance or behavior anxiety
irritability insomnia dysphoria
and intrusive thoughts of wanting to use
their drug again
now with enough time elapsed and again
with people in people with severe
addiction it can take
months to years those neuro-adaptation
gremlins will hop off we will regenerate
our own dopamine and our own dopamine
receptors and and our level balance or
homeostasis will be restored is it
scientific to call them gremlins super
scientific
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify